the problem with men you don't want it
because you can't handle it but then you
don't want to be monogamous if you can't
be monogamous be single don't be with
one person
why would they why would they have to
why would they like I mean I'm sorry if
you're in the top 10 20 of guys they
don't have to just be single they can
have them
immediately go stop when they can get a
girlfriend cheat on her and we just talk
to the panel y'all stay no no
this is the problem it's not that it's
not that you need to have a girlfriend
and cheat on you have a girlfriend and
tell her I'm not monogamous so if you
want to be with me and I give you these
perks yeah but why would he do that when
he can just cheat on you and you also
but this isn't but then when you get the
toxic behavior from her don't moan when
she then vandalizes your whole property
okay okay why why do we why do we put
our bad decisions on demand okay isn't
that like you're just toxic because it's
because I like I've I've been cheated on
before it wasn't it wasn't fun but I
never did anything toxic or crazy or any
any of the [ __ ] that I hear girls say
that that's a you that's a you problem
no man no man can make you do crazy you
should hear either crazy or you're not
no do you know what it is for me
personally I don't call it crazy things
I just [ __ ] I call it disrespect and
reacting to disrespect okay for example
I feel like when a woman doesn't react
and a man cheats and he gets away with
it he doesn't learn that this has hurt
or impacted someone when a woman then
reacts he has to either have discussions
with her or he needs to realize right
this was a reproduction of it okay but
but in these situations everyone reacted
and on the couch
I'm saying even you reacted you were
going through his phone you were telling
him like whatever and and like looking
at his messages or I can't remember
exactly how you said you found out so
you did react he didn't learn his lesson
because he had like a million side
pieces no no no but he never
confirmed that he cheated or anything
but that's what I'm saying and my
reactions were they yeah when I first
left when I left when I first got the
okay this must be confirmation because
of obviously all the girls
yeah I reacted to that yeah and he was
like I can't tolerate this cool and then
I left him but then he did write me
letters saying he wants me back
sorry I just want to say it I don't
think I don't think you necessarily need
to react because I know you made a point
about reacting for him to understand
that this is wrong because I don't react
like the way you react I think that's
this is how I react to things if you do
something that's wild that's crazy
disrespectful to me I'm sorry cool
that's what you've done and I keep you
moving so with me in my situation I did
I didn't react I let you know that okay
this is what you did this is not on it's
not something I want to stand for and I
kept it moving and years later he still
wanting to have me back yeah but I don't
think you need to necessarily react to
get to let a guy understand what he's
doing wrong yeah and I also I agree what
you said earlier where you said how
because I think I hear a lot of women
sometimes say stuff like oh he made me
crazy
you're either either you're either crazy
no so my point is
refer to it as a woman reacting to it
however she reacts for me I wouldn't say
it's crazy because I feel like societies
say oh it's crazy that's her reaction
that's crazy
but the reason I say is emotions no but
what exactly I'm saying it's her
expressing her emotions and she's in
Rage and raised about a child you're not
okay you guys wait you're not you're not
a child you're a grown adult I'm sorry
if you're gonna stop stop interrupting
me you're not a child you're a grown
adult if you make if you do something
crazy you're crazy you can't blame it on
other people like nobody can make you do
anything like that that's that's like
what a child would say I think can I can
I just sex I haven't really spoken but I
just want to say an observation that
I've made in this conversation so the
younger ladies have proven a point which
I don't know if anyone's noticed they
looked for a problem they wound
themselves up Auntie said she
experienced a similar thing but she
didn't wind herself up she responded to
the situation as the situation happened
and she didn't go in there like I'm
gonna do this I'm gonna do that I think
they're looking for it like you said
yeah so the difference is within the
modern women
we're looking for the problem and when
we amp ourselves up in the situation
we're actually reacting before we get to
the point where we're with the man so
we're already angry and because there's
so much on social media and so much
access to different women at the same
time
we're literally winding ourselves up if
you look for it you're gonna find it we
know that and you're responsible yeah
and exactly and that's what it does it
shows your maturity level and your
um emotional management so you know like
at work if someone pisses you off you
know how to manage it you know you're
not just going to flip out and start
Carson because you don't want to lose
your job that's your livelihood but in
this situation you haven't really
calculated how you're going to manage
the situation you've just reacted and I
think as a younger woman like in this
generation we're very reactionary to
what's going on around us rather than
um sorry grounding ourselves first and
then having like a clear fool and and
then responding you know I think I could
actually get older you take a break
realize that though like everyone's
gonna yeah it's always it's a waste of
energy it's literally a waste of energy
I remember being like 14 and finding out
you know someone's cheating and you
would go absolutely mad at them and
you'd cry and you know you'd get really
angry and then as you get older like you
said you'd realize you just you know
yeah if you're gonna do it fine cool
I'll leave you do whatever you want
there's no point in wasting your energy
when you're not going to get anything
back from anyway because I think women
need to understand that and again I'm
not advocate for it Bob in most
instances men will be men so all this
angle all this blowing up it doesn't it
doesn't affect no one but you because
like you said
women seem to think that by getting
angry the guy's gonna change or he's
gonna see it differently he's probably
still going to do the same thing just
so it's like is that when when do women
come to the realization that
that's how they're built you're built
different because what and this is what
I've seen before is that there's two
lenses there's your lens and it's the
Mel lens but you're only see things
through your lens so how you perceive
sex is how you think men to see sex and
it's completely different and what I'd
like to know is after you found out and
you went back how is your behavior
towards him after that
you got me would you trust him again or
was you always watching him or was done
his phone
irritating him I was having a dig but I
think that's the end of the relationship
anyway
no point like yeah
go ahead if there's no point
you know there's no point but you're
continuing relationship I think I think
women that stay it's not because they
want to continue I think it's the
emotions of love and having to like
grieve the relationship while they're
there and I think eventually they get
over it I don't think they go back it's
the one team that they're in you don't
want to you don't want to get rid of the
routine but then also you have women
that will break up with guys in their
head before they've broke up with them
yeah exactly and then when you leave
it's not as hard but in a caveat today
is that look if if if we're gonna go off
the pretense that most men behave this
way and the men that you're attracted to
are in a small like percentage of men
who will do the same thing anyway
doesn't it make more sense to stay
with the devil that you know then seek
something else new outside
because you know or you can be allow
yourself
[Music]
if you allow yourself to feel that pain
then you can move through it and past it
when you sit on it or you go back you
have it there like you're waiting for
something you're anticipating another
cheating you don't feel the pain you're
not going to feel happiness yeah you
don't move through it and I think when
one once a man cheats especially with
like social media and all these things
um we have these experiences and then
we're anticipating something going wrong
and then we kind of provoke it to happen
if we don't work with it like together
as a couple then it's not gonna work
nothing there's no communication in that
I think some women weigh up their risks
and the rewards because I've I don't
think I'm I always say here that if your
partner cheats on you yeah if you're
going to stay
then you need to be staying to move
forward I don't believe in staying with
someone and every chance you get you're
bringing yourself yeah why are you here
let me make my life miserable but I also
think that there are women as well who
weigh up the realities of life I feel
like with a lot a lot of what a lot of
people think about love it's very um
fairy tale it's very yeah it's wishful
thinking yeah but the realities of life
is that I'm at this age for example
we've been married blah blah blah you've
cheated this is one this is the one time
I've caught you cheating blah blah yeah
what am I going to lose if I walk away
from this and what's really out there so
I think some some women have to
they just work through it they think
that you know I can't bother to do all
of this again I'm gonna have to find
somebody I'm gonna have to be single
going for a divorce yeah or break up and
then I've spent I have this much time
I've invested so much time in this
relationship you know let's just let me
forget let's forgive it and let's move
forward and do whatever it is that we
need to do to come to understanding that
this can't happen again yeah and I think
I don't I don't see anything wrong with
that stuff
yes if you listen to what they're saying
they actually stay and plan to leave
yeah men just leave women always stay
and plan to leave that's why women get
divorced they lose so much because the
women have been planning it
very few times
you they cheat and then you actually get
past it and have a happy life what I'd
like to know is I think
I think that people used to get past it
all the time I think modern women can't
because we've been sold a bill of girls
that men can't live up to and we're told
that he has to be taller than us make
money like be basically Prince Charming
and not cheat on you but it's like if
you want a guy on a certain level he's
probably gonna cheat
I think that women romanticize love too
much realistically love is something
that transforms every day when you're
working on it and if you're not working
on it with your partner then it's not
love if you're going to look at love as
a romantic thing so kind gestures every
day your mind's going to be considerate
to you every day it's going to be in
your favor
you have that mentality of entitlement
just because you're in the relationship
and I think from like my experience of
observation men get tired of that
because what's the benefits to them you
know you want more no matter how much
they give It's never enough and then
once they've given the Max Capacity they
can go to somebody else who wants much
less and is happy with that and they're
not going to cause aggravation you find
out about it and then you kick off so it
kind of undoes all the work that's been
put into the relationship on his side
then he loses everything and then like
what's the benefit that's why it should
always be 50 50. so the guy puts in the
energy you know he's being considerate a
fetching the flowers and stuff like that
but then there's no flowers
still do it but then like the girl needs
to give the energy it's about gratitude
it's about gratitude and reciprocity as
well
what have you done
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible